[Music]
he's played in UCLA the one who's not
being taken off a screen CJ nice pass
from Dave will let it beautifully
bypassed and CJ basic before to cut
lasers at once seven in a row here at
home that was after they had lost six
and everybody wanted to know
the world is going on and I think you
would agree everybody at the beautiful
Pasadena CJ moving without the ball the
poles need a I want the red a bold red
flag anything else so you folks adhere
to the uniform when I get to work
CJ on the bottle following jumper up and
in the pool was right down one of the
left lasers a tiller the knocks down his
second three the quarter Kevin McHale
it's outstanding things to say
another three look Rollo has actually
made the most success very subtle CJ we
saw what you did there
well he gives that tons of confidence CJ
hesitates gets to the mid-range and
knocks down another it truly is the
bastard here he comes to
fire three and flushes a three-parter
the wrong age they're trying to work the
ball team with all the death and
attention he's getting you might be able
to get somebody else open but no need if
they're gonna play in straight-up 101
tip 3 with CJ in the frontcourt say he
doing it again he's doing it again
that's what he almost did the time
before this Tainted similar impact not
attempt at eighth grade Duncan all
people really have that backpack full of
his his dad's Richard Levine taken away
handy COMSAT McCollum
can also buy
they fear wait a minute I think I see
you Chicago Bulls go Bulls no we're
giving a little bit too much attention
back to the game CJ down the lane the
floater
he three points 22 minutes drilling off
the straight CJ to the glass Terry
Stotts paces this an anxious moment for
Coach you've got your team is playing so
well
CJ outside a Tripoli lets it go davis
outside the screen CJ looking for the
career-high right here got it 45 for CJ
McCollum a career-high remarkable start
to this ball game good defense CJ goes
underneath Zack goes over the top and CJ
go ahead and add to it step back from
three
[Applause]